la question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre 150 citoyens 149
propositions retenues dimanche dernier
par une convention citoyenne pour le
climat pour nous dire comment se loger
se nourrir se déplacer consommez
travailler et produire neuf mois de
travail en milieu armée de 150 citoyens
tirés au sort
triés sur le volet vert pas forcément
vertueux sans être élu comment comment
serait-il légitime pour parler au nom de
66 millions d'habitants leur avis pour
être pris en compte par les décideurs
politiques mais ils n'ont nullement la
légitimité des lunes la nation pour
prendre des décisions au nom du peuple
qui apport présentant nos élus
municipaux départementaux régionaux
parlementaires députés et six sénateurs
le président de la république a confirmé
hier je cite le plan de relance ne peut
pas passer par les régions et des
départements
si l'on respecte le calendrier électoral
c'est une drôle de conception de la
démocratie comme si elle était devenue
un obstacle à l'efficacité au contraire
en période de crise la démocratie est
encore plus une ressource des
propositions sont irréalistes et
déconnectés du terrain
monsieur le premier ministre avec la
proposition de cette convention de
limiter la vitesse à 110 km/heure sur
les autoroutes
êtes vous prêts à renouveler
l'expérience malheureuse du 80 km/heure
et pensez vous que la réduction du temps
de travail à 28 heures payées 35
relancera l'économie
attention aux interdictions et aux
contraintes supplémentaires que dénoncer
déjà nos gloires et fait taire dans nos
territoires
attention à la promotion idéologique de
fausses vérités en supprimant les vols
intérieurs pour des prétextes
environnementaux non suffisamment
justifié n'emprunte carbone aériennes et
de 4 7%
vous nous emmener vers une décroissance
mortifère de nos territoires en les
déconnectant des mobilités et de
l'accessibilité merci monsieur monsieur
le premier ministre vous le savez ces
propositions sur liberticide ne sont pas
l'émanation de la volonté du peuple là
il faut la caisse
vous qu'elles vont chauffer la france et
sauver la planète
madame elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire pour
vous répondre
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur les sénateurs boyer écoutez
vous voyez moi je pense que quand 150
citoyens tirés au sort
à l'image de notre pays prennent sur
leur temps personnel pour travailler
avec beaucoup de détermination
pendant neuf mois avec beaucoup de
sérieux
cela mérite le respect cela mérite le
respect alors qu'est ce que nous disent
ces citoyens ils nous disent
et je précise qu au départ ces citoyens
vous savez certains étaient climato
sceptiques ils nous l'ont dit qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent ils nous disent que
des premiers week-ends ils ont pu
échanger avec des experts avec des
scientifiques et qu'ils ont pris une
claque qu'ils ont pris une claque en
réalisant l'ampleur du défi climatique
et sur cette base on joue confirment
qu'ils ont travaillé en auditionnant des
industriels en auditionnant des élus en
auditionnant sans doute des
parlementaires et sur la base de tout ce
travail ils nous ont remis effectivement
ils nous ont remis une vision globale de
nombreuses propositions et je pense que
vraiment le reste et impose de ne pas
sortir de mettre en exergue quelques
mesures alors que le principe du travail
qui a été réalisé par ses citoyens
c'est vraiment d'apporter des réponses
globales sur la rénovation des bâtiments
sur la syphilis artificialisation des
sols sur le développement de la mobilité
propre sur le renforcement du fret
ferroviaire et je pense que sur tous ces
sujets il ya un large consensus sur
l'intérêt d'aller dans ce sens du reste
nous avons une occasion de débattre de
projets de lois qui portent ces mêmes
orientations
alors effectivement je pense que c'est
important que le débat se poursuivre
les consensus qui ont été trouvés entre
des citoyens ils doivent continuer à se
construire dans la société
que ce soit à l'occasion d'un débat
parlementaire ou d'un référendum
donc on est bien d'accord monsieur le
sénateur il faut que le débat se
poursuivre notamment ici même au sénat